so what does oom need you for but
doesn't matter now I'm not gonna stick
around much longer wait I thought you
said your powers don't work inside this
cell they've done your right so you're
gonna help me get out of here boy would
I help you listen honey there's no way
you are making it down that Cliff all by
yourself
so let's make a deal you get me out of
this box
and I'll help you get home I might even
throw in some more drill tips for free
hey youtubers is Charlie winter is
coming so we learned a little bit about
what's going on with killer frost in
season 3 so there's just gonna be a
breakdown so the big news is that Kevin
Smith is directing episode 7 of the
flash he just started this week and it
seems like the title some of the text on
this page that you can barely make out
that it's a killer frost episode so
first big thing big hell yeah totally
awesome don't know if it's going to be
our version of Kaitlyn that turns into
killer frost that would be a pretty
freakin big episode or if it's gonna be
an alternate universe version or if
there's gonna be another character on
earth 1 to become killer frost because
one of the big changes with earth 1
Kaitlyn's story that they've already
confirmed is that her mother is coming
on the show and they actually referenced
her during season 2 when she and killer
frost were locked up and killer frost
made a joke about their mother being a
in both universes so her mother's
gonna come on the show she's gonna be
like this really big biotech person
who's kind of like an eel bard thawne
version of Tina McGee in that you know
she's like a very successful scientist
but has the personality of eobard thawne
seems like a really not nice person a
frigid personality make all the ice puns
that you can think of but I'm wondering
if they're gonna weave it in to killer
frost backstory from the comics like
they're gonna do some fun spin on killer
frost this season and it's gonna involve
her mother and there's gonna be a couple
deep cuts from the comics because there
had been three big versions of killer
frost in the comics caitlin snow is just
the most recent version she really
didn't
killer frost until the new 52 the first
version of killer frost is called
crystal frost and she was actually part
of the firestorm Comics killer frost was
a big part of the firestorm comics all
the way back in the 70s and 80s in the
80s Louise Lincoln became killer frost
during like the Wally West era of the
flash so there's all kinds of story that
they could pull from she even teamed up
with mr. freeze icicle and Captain Cold
for this big Superman Batman crossover
but I'm not expecting them to do that
anytime soon
but whatever they end up doing with
killer frost this season it'll all be
based on the stuff that they're already
doing on the TV show the stuff they did
last season they usually try to avoid
retreading stuff so keep in mind the
flash points gonna change some big
things probably something big about
Caitlin's character I feel like the
biggest thing that they could do is turn
her into a metahuman Cisco style where
it's not like completely visible but
then later she has an accident in the
season and becomes killer frost we
haven't really seen footage beyond the
first episode Caitlin appears here in
STAR Labs treating wally west so as far
as we know she's normal Caitlin when the
season picks up but you know a whole
bunch of stuff can happen in those first
couple of episodes if you remember we
got Gorilla Grodd relatively quickly
last season we got our new version of
firestorm so they're gonna debut a whole
bunch of new characters you know both
bad and good so whatever it's gonna be
happening in episode 7 in this Kevin
Smith episode it is going to be killer
frost centric and it's going to be some
big WTF moment because this is going to
be happening during a time of year when
sweeps is happening when networks push
like their biggest WTF moments so that
they guarantee eyeballs in the United
States is this big advertising period so
TV shows try to do like their big events
during this specific time it's like at
the end of November beginning of
December so that's why they're doing the
big four night crossover during this
period too so leading up to it they want
to do everything they can to get you to
watch the flash so they're doing a fan
favorite character from the TV show
killer frost and they're probably going
to do some crazy event that will help
lead into what's happening during the
big four night crossover so remember
last year Kevin Smith directed the
runaway dinosaur episode that was a
really big episode they did a bunch of
big things we
this big revelation about the nature of
the speedforce there's like an
intelligence behind it
their speed forts wormhole aliens very
seemingly comes back from the dead
Cisco uses his powers in a way that he
had never done before just a lot of big
things happen in that episode so in that
same vein episode 7 probably going to be
dropping some giant killer frost bombs
so let me know what do you want them to
do with the killer frost character this
season do you want to see earth one
Caitlyn turn into killer frost do you
want to see earth two killer frost come
back or do you want to see another
multiverse version of the character I
feel like part of the way they changed
the show each year with different plot
devices like the big worm hole in the
sky flashpoint as a way to kind of
refresh the characters like look it's
the same actor but it's kind of a
different character I feel like it'd be
really hard for them going forward to
turn earth one Caitlyn into killer frost
and then take that back in the future
season so just be prepared for a killer
frost on the TV show to not be our earth
one Caitlyn in from a production
standpoint it's actually hard just to
have danielle Panabaker walking around
in all that makeup it's like a crazy
amount of makeup it takes way longer
than it would normally take to get her
on set for like a hundred and eighty
days a year for filming as killer frost
so I know everybody's getting hype about
killer frost just a reminder there is a
new round of the flash season two
blu-ray giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video there's gonna be a whole
bunch more Marvel DC stuff happening
this week but also just as a reminder
YouTube brought some updates so you can
actually click on the links that I add
at the end of videos now if there is a
bug it should go away pretty quickly but
let me know in the comments if you guys
do have trouble clicking on those links
at the end while you guys wait for that
to post you can click here to watch the
last big flash trailer I just posted you
can click here to watch the latest Ghost
Rider agents of shield trailer thank you
so much watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight